WE HAVE FOX TEAM COVERAGE ON
THIS.
BRIT HUME TELLS US PERHAPS WHAT
IT ALL MEANS.
CONOR POWELL IN JERUSALEM.
FIRST BACK TO CHIEF WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT JOHN ROBERTS ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
IT WAS A YEAR AND TWO DAYS AGO
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP UNLEASHED
THE POWER OF THE U.S. MILITARY
AGAINST SYRIA, FIRING 59
TOMAHAWK CRUISE MISSILES AT AN
AIR BASE FROM WHICH THE LAST
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ATTACK WAS
LAUNCHED.
AT THE TIME, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WARNED BASHAR AL-ASSAD THERE
WOULD BE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES IF
HE DID IT AGAIN.
IT LOOKS LIKE ASSAD DID NOT
LISTEN.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THAT ALL
OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE TO
RESPOND TO THE SUSPECTED
CHEMICAL WHAT -- WEAPONS ATTACK.
>> WE ARE MEETING WITH THE